فيديوهات كثيره نشرت اليوم من قبل الفصائل
الفلسطينيه لسير المعارك في قطاع غزه من
الشمال الى الجنوب نحللها مع اللواء فيس
دويري الخبير العسكري واست جي مرحبا بك
لواء دويري عبد القادر اطلعنا على ابرز
التفاصيل بدء من الشمال اعتقد نعم جلال
ولعل تطورات في الشمال والوسط والجنوب
وننطلق فعلا من منطقه الشمال وحينما نذكر
منطقه الشمال نذكر بانها المنطقه التي
شهدت بدايات التوغل الاسرائيلي خصوصا من
المنطقه من مناطق بيت لاهيه وبيت حانون
الى اخره لكن الجديد هو هذه الاشتباكات
المعلن عنها عبر اكثر من منطقه القسام
تتحدث عن اشتباكات في منطقه الكرامه وكانت
ايضا من المواقع الاولى التي استهدفت من
قبل القوات الاسرائيليه ولكن ايضا ابراج
ابراج المخابرات ومنطقه الشيخ رضوان كان
هناك ايضا اشتباكات وايضا استهداف لاليات
عسكريه شرق منطقه التفاح وفي التفاصيل
هناك حديث عن كمين في منطقه الكرامه لجنود
اسرائيليين او تحديدا لمنزل تحصن فيه جنود
اسرائيلي في منطقه الكرامه قالت القسام
بانه تم استهدافهم بقذائف الياسين لكن كان
ايضا هناك استهداف لاليات عسكريه هنا في
الشيخ رضوان
وايضا كان هناك ايضا استهداف ل ناقله جند
هنا في منطقه جباليه جباليه التي تعرضت
الى قصف عنيف خلال الايام الماضيه لكن كان
هناك ايضا استهداف ل لنقله جند هنا في هذه
المنطقه تحديدا شرق التفاح وتحديدا في جبل
الريس اذا هذه الجبهات او هذا المربع
الكبير يعود الى الواجهه من خلال هذه
الاشتباكات التي تاخذها المقاومه مع طبعا
عمليه قصف استهدفت الدرج كان هناك عشرات
الشهداء ايضا تل الهوا تعرضت الى عمليات
قصف مماثل بالذهاب الى المنطقه الوسطى لعل
هناك امر لافت وهو وهذه الاعلانات
والبيانات لكتائب القسام ولسر القدس عن
اشتباكات من المصافه صفر في اكثر من موقع
نتحدث بالاساس عن مخيم المغازي نتحدث عن
مخيم المغازي ولكن ايضا نتحدث عن مخيم
البريج حيث في المغازي كانت كتائب القسام
قد اعلنت عن استهداف عدد من الدبابات
الاسرائيليه وتدميرها تدميرا كليا استهداف
ناقلات جند ولكن اللفت ايضا ما اعلنته
ايضا را القدس عن امر مماثل من خلال
اشتباكات واستهداف لاليات عسكريه في مخيم
البريج وحينما نتحدث عن هذين المخيمين فقد
شهد عمليه قصف مكثفه خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه اضافه الى النصيرات والزوايده
ودير البلح اذا جبهه الوسط ايضا تعلن عن
نفسها من خلال هذه البيانات لكتائب
المقاومه لكن بالذهاب الى الجنوب لعل
التطور الابر هو ايضا هذه الاشتباكات في
منطقه خان يونس ولعلي انطلق من الخبر الذي
تناولناه اليوم والمتعلق ب عمليه انزال
جوي هنا في خان يونس لامداد قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي ب الوقود والغذاء ولكن
بالاسلحه والعتاد وهي العمليه الخامسه في
قطاع غزه منذ بدايه الحرب والعمليه
الثانيه في خان يونس بعد تلك التي قدها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في الحا من ديسمبر ياتي
ذلك في ظل تطورات ميدانيه بالاساس في
المنطقه الوسطى من خان يونس وايضا المنطقه
الغربيه التي تعرضت الى عمليه قصف
اسرائيلي مكثف كانت هناك اشتباكات
للمقاومه وكتائب القسام مع القوات
الاسرائيليه خصوصا في منطقه البلد ومنطقه
المحطه والكتيبه وايضا قرب مستشفى ناصر
وكان ايضا بالاجمال كان هناك اشتباكات في
المنطقه الجنوبيه وجاءت هذه الاعلانات من
كتائب القسام عن استهداف مجموعات راجله
قوات راجله هنا في منطقه معا ولكن ايضا
سرايا القدس اعلنت ايضا عن استهداف قوات
راجله واليه عسكريه في قرب كليه العلوم
والتكنولوجيا اذا تطورات لافته ايضا في
الجنوب تضاف الى تطورات الوسط والشمال
واتابع مع اللواء دويري من خان يونس حيث
قال قبل قليل اللواء دويري الناطق العسكري
بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يوسع هجومه في
خانيونس لانه رصد كتيبه لحماس واطلاق
صواريخ ايضا من خانيونس
ما الذي يلفتك في طريقه هجوم الجيش
الاسرائيلي على خان يونس بصوره عامل هجوم
متعثر بصوره عامه الهجوم متعثر وهناك
اثباتات من الميدان يتحدث ه جاري كما يشاء
الان اذا نظرنا الى
الخارطه القراره وزنه كانت هي مسرح
العمليات الرئيسي لمده تقارب الاسبوع فشلت
القوات جيش الاحتلال في فرض واقع ي مكنها
من
التثبت فكان الاجراء سحب جل هذه القوات
وتم سحبها باتجاه كفيم من اجل اعاده بناء
قدراتها
القتاليه اذا نظرنا في المنطقه الشرقيه
لديه عمليات منذ بدء العمليه في الاطراف
الشماليه لعب سار الجديده ولم تستطع
الوصول الى شارع صلاح الدين وعملت ستك
داون في الارض ا اذا ذهبنا للمنطقه الجن
هناك ذراع اخر
للهجوم يحاول ان يلتقي معه من جنوب عبسان
الكبيره
ولكنه كما واجه في الشمال يواجه في الجنوب
الجنوب الان منطقه خزاعه خصص لها لواء
كامل وهذا اللواء لم يستطع
دخولها دمر مربعات سكنيه كامله في خزاعه
وفي بن سهيله ولكنه انكف الى خارج السياج
ماذا بقي له من اعمال هناك عمليه الاحاطه
من اتجاه اي ابراج الحمد ووصولا الى
المواس جوش قطيف دخل بالامس كان اشار عبقا
عبد القادر الى السدود الناريه وكانت
السدود الناريه توحي بان هناك شيئ ما اما
عمليه انزال بحري لمساعده الهجوم المتعثر
او عمليات انزال جوي وكان الخيار هو انزال
جوي وهذا الخيار الانزال الجوي هو مثير
للسخريه لماذا
الانزال الجوي امريكا كانت نفذت جسر
جوي على مدار عده اشهر من امريكا الى لين
جراد من اجل تثبيت القوات السوفيتيه ضد
الهجوم الجيش الالماني ونجحت اذا نحن
نتحدث عندما نكون هناك عمليات امداد بالجو
نتحدث عن خطوط امداد طويله جدا وصعبه
ومعقده انا الان اتحدث من من كوس فيم الى
شارع الرشيد في هذه المنط 17 17 م لا
يستطيع ان يؤمن ثمانيه الويه تعمل في هذه
المنطقه ولا تستطيع ان تؤمن ممر لنقل
المواد اللوازم الدفاعيه هذا مثير للسخريه
يعني انت تقول ان هناك تعثر طيب هو اشار
الى هذه النقطه ايضا دانييل ها جاري قال
بان سحب القوات هو لراحتها لانها لا
تستطيع ان ان تح لوقت طويل وتجهيزها اعاده
تجهيزها وتدريبها سيدي لماذا تسحب القوه
تسحب القوه لجمله عبء ام تدني مستوى
الجاهزيه القتاليه لديها سواء في بعد
المعدات او بعد الافراد او في البعد
المعنوي ا والبعد اللوجستي من حيث الامداد
هو عانت من كل هذه الامور عانت من خسائر
قاسيه في المعدات خسائر قاسيه في الافراد
عدم تحقيق نتيجه ولم تستطع وبالتالي كان
لابد من سحبها لانه لو بقيت ستصبح لقمه
سائغه للقوات المقاتله المقابله هذا ما
حدث مع الفرقه س 30 وليس مع فقط هذه
القوات الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكن ان يقول
انه انجزه وهو لم يذكره انا اساعده هو
هجوم كتيبه من منطقه الفخاري جنوب عسار
الكبيره قطعت شارع صلاح الدين ووصلت
الى
قيز منطقه قيزيل النجار والى اطراف الكليه
التطبيقيه و لم تستطع التثبت وانكفا وخرجت
من منطقه النجار بلده النجار هذا هو
الانجاز الرئيسي الوحيد الذي استطاع ان ان
يقدمه في داخل خان يونس منذ عشره ايام
استطاع الدخول الى ثلاث مناطق الكتيبه
والمحطه
و والسجن ولا يزال ستاك ان والقتال يدور
ضمن خطوط قتاليه شبه ثابته واض واضح عبسان
الجديده وعبس الكبيره تتردد اسمائهم ما
كثيرا في الاعلام العسكري العبري ما الذي
يرسم لهاتين المنطقتين هذه المنطقه تعتبر
منطقه واسعه شبكه الالغام فيها معقده
فتحات الانفاق كثيره جدا يصعب
احصائها تعطي القوات المقاومه درجه عاليه
من المرونه في الظهور كسمكه الصحراء في
المكان والزمان غير المعلومين وتباشر
مقاربتها تحت مفهوم الترويع والصدمه
وبالتالي مجرد ظهورهم يعنيي تدمير اليه لا
يعلم من اين يخرج كيف يخرج متى يخرج
وبالتالي هذه المنطقه لا يجر على الحركه
فيها ولهذا السبب انا اشرت لك ان هذه
المنطقه تخضع الى تدمير مربعات سكنيه
كامله عمليه انتقام من اولا انتقام وثانيا
من اجل تهيئه ارضيه معينه تسمح له
بالمناور وفي المنطقه الوسطى للعلم الموقف
اكثر تحقد اها لماذا قبل الانتقال ال
الوسطى هل هل ممكن ان جيش الاحتلال يسعى
لخل طق ما يعرف عسكريا بالبف زون او منطقه
عازله بعبسه الجديده وعبس الكبيره كما فعل
في في الشمال لا يا سيدي هون الوضع هو لم
يستطع الدخول هو دخل من الاجزاء الشماليه
منطقه عبسال الجديده دخل عده مئات من
الامتار وصلت في حد الاقصى 600 متر واجبر
على التراجع ولم يعد يشن اي مناوره جديده
كذلك في منطقه عبسان الجديده هو الان
يعتمد عمليات القصف الممنهج الدخول السريع
الى باحجام صغيره سريه وك
كعمليات جس النبض لاكتشاف ثغرات معينه اي
بمعنى اخر تحول من عمليه الهجوم الفعلي
الى المناوره الهجوميه ليبحث عن نقاط ضعف
لعله يستغلها ويطور من عملياته سريعا
بدقيقه ونصف لنتحدث عن الجبهه الوسطى
اللواء الدويري ما الذي لديك لتقوله
الجبهه الوسطى يوجد الان لوائين في
المنطقه الشماليه من البريج وان صيرات هذه
تثبتت مؤقتا وبدات تبني
سواتر ترابيه ومرابض دبابات من اجل تامين
الحمايه وهي ليست في حاله اشتباك مباشر
الا اشتباك بالنيران في الان
البريج يتم مهاجمته وهنا يطبق المناوره
الهجوميه لا يزال يبحث عن نقاط ضعف سواء
في محيط البريج ان سيرات بصوره عامه ثبتت
العمليات القتاليه فيه ولا يوجد فيه سوى
اشتباك ناري الزوايده والمغازي مخيمات
صغيره وبالتالي يحاول ان يدخل بها دخل في
الزوايده الى منطقه الحديقه العامه وفي
المغازي
الى
اطراف الجنوبيه الغربيه منه ولكن هناك
معارك ضايه تحت مفهوم المناوره العمليات
اكثر منها هجوم مباشر سؤال الاخير لاحظنا
اليوم ب فيديوهات فصائل المقاومه استخدام
مكثف للهاون ما الذي يعني هذا من هذا الان
يوجد تجمعات انا ذكرت لك على سبيل المثال
في المنطقه الشماليه شمال النصيرات
والبريج الان قلت لك يوجد لوائين متواجدين
في هذه المنطقه الان اذا ذهبنا شمالا
قليلا الى منطقه الوادي من جحر
الديك من غرب جحر الديك حتى الرشيد العمق
5 ك متر هي تعتبر منطقه تكدس للقوات
وبالتالي التعامل معها يكون من خلال هو
سلاح ناجع شكرا لك اللواء في الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي